si è così bella che ti ragazzi e
benvenuto questo video sono fa vj e anzi
dobbiamo fare come gli occhiali devono
rendermi un po più signore facciamo che
quando me li metto sembra un po più
serio rosa veramente difficile quindi
siccome adesso gli occhiali vies plico
in modo molto molto signorile come mai
gli omessi della tutti ragazzi e sono un
fa vj e oggi siamo in un nuovo blog come
in ogni sabato prima di cominciare come
di consueto partiamo con la fa notte
della settimana che questa settimana non
l'ho scelta perché sarà anche signorile
nella voce ma non so organizzarmi un
cazzo questa settimana è stata vinta da
vanessa è affatto questo meraviglioso
disegno risalente al 1800 inquadro
moderno tendente al neorealismo con un
pizzino di stile vangogh diano un
applauso concitato alla nostra vanessa
che ha dedicato tempo della sua vita per
fare questa fan ha detto questo passiamo
alle durante la settimana ha avuto
l'incredibile piacere di essere ospitato
dal signor cattelan nella sua
trasmissione televisiva e abbiamo
intrattenuto al nostro pubblico e
saziando lo con decorose e dignitose i
giochi moderni
vabbè ok non ce la sto più facendo
abbiate pazienza vi spiego sta cosa
perché non è possibile sono in realtà
questi non sono occhiali da vista quindi
non è che me li devo mettere sempre sono
chiari senza gradazione significa che io
anche senza vedo bene vedo 12 decimi
senza quindi vedo meglio di voi non mi
sono fatto troppe pippe che mi hanno
consigliato di metterli davanti al
computer perché essendo troppo tempo
davanti al pc perché io per registrare i
video per montarli si passò praticamente
la giornata davanti al computer è lì per
fare il video di 10 minuti si mette
dieci minuti li malata piante alcuni
hanno consigliato di metterli per
evitare di sforzare la vista è quindi
quando farò video ogni tanto li metterò
nel caso state tranquilli che non sto
invecchiando sto solo perché la barba
ancora mai cresciuta se tu vai sterile
vi può essere appunto alla cagata che
stavo dicendo prima sono stato ospite al
epcc che sarebbe la trasmissione di
cattelan
insieme abbiamo commentato dei siti
strani non so perché io ho portato dopo
le cuffie quindi na figata vi faccio
vedere degli spezzoni perché è troppo
figo puoi schiaffeggiare un tizio con un
anguilla
lo so che utilità possa avere e
bellissimo vero dai 13 45 video con
questo maggio quanto da settimane
lavorano anche espressione come di
rimanere segreta dell'anguilla proprio
sulla facciata che parte come una
schermata nera ma se poi tu punti
il mouse su un punto dello schermo si
trova una foto di un tizio che indica
esattamente quel punto
e poi abbiamo fatto lancia b bagni
challenge in diretta tv cosa ne sto
facendo della mia vita subito dopo la
puntata mi hanno detto di mettere gli
occhiali per sembrare un po più
intelligente per occhiali o meno il mio
cervello rimane grosso come quello della
mosca morta quindi non cambia un cazzo
sono anche figli camerini di sky devo
essere sincero mi ci sono perso due o
tre volte o non lo troverete visto
lorenzo ha grande grazie
[Musica]
come si toglie questa cosa per fortuna
ho avuto un attimo di non diamo un
cannavaro sarebbe fiero di me infatti mi
ha chiesto un self bellissimo
orca traiana vita e completa ragazzi è
stato troppo figo cioè non ho parole poi
sono simpaticissimo incontrato anche
gattuso e sono simpaticissimi è sorta
recentemente una conversazione con una
donzella che ha tentato l'approccio con
me direttamente su facebook e la
suddetta chat era alquanto bizzarra
della mostra primo messaggio 18 gennaio
lo vorresti un massaggio ai piedi da me
perché non già siamo cagata il giorno
dopo risposta impaziente di mission o ma
so cagata mango le 10 aprile quindi ben
tre mesi dopo torna alla riscossa
dovresti un bel massaggia aridaje co ste
cazzo dei messaggi pieni
vabbè equa arriva la risposta mi ha però
io vivo con le scarpe risposta su al
giorno dopo non mi sembrava affatto ho
visto un tuo video doveri al mare nel
pattino ed eri scalzo è solo una bugia
mia zia come sei arguta lunedì mi mal di
una tua foto sexy seguenti punti
interrogativi ininterrotti sinonimo di
impazienza ed ecco la mia risposta
sono fiero di me stesso cazzo la sua
risposta tua a perché ha notato che non
era mia per non è che ha detto no ma sto
tizio non è sexy lei pensa che sia sexy
però la vuole mia la foto non so a cosa
ti toglieresti per me e qui arriva il
bello la mia risposta ovviamente è stata
le scarpe così mi fa il massaggio non le
tolgo da quando avevo sei anni quindi è
un privilegio
va bene vai e poi praticamente io l'ho
mandato la foto del mio capetti che non
è il mio capezzolo prove e lei se n'è
accorta e si vede male si vede che non
sei tu non ci casca maio a migliaia
ragazza più furba del mondo che sfiga di
merda direi di passare al prossimo punto
perché allora social fei si sta piacendo
troppo ma giuro da un'anteprima delle
puntate che usciranno la prossima non ci
sono io però guardatela perché
fighissima della prossima ancora quella
di giovedì ci sarò anch'io e vi do un
breve assaggio ma pro breve ma come
l'art
non esplode in un posto vacante
per i sempre con te questo da oggi sta
nel tono a di granchio con le mani così
e cioè per dire diventare sicurezza il
caschetto la sicurezza è sempre
importante la strategia però
l'ignoranza anzi adesso sono più
ignorante l'ultimo punto di oggi ragazzi
allora non vi avevo ancora fatto vedere
questo gameplay epico c'era ancora una
cosa che non avevo messo nel video del
texas praticamente ho sfidato a
valentino rossi the game
mi scappava scusate tanto gli occhiali
coprono la mia rosa g ho avuto l'onore
di sfidare i piloti di moto 3 a
valentino rossi dei games e io ho
giocato contro di loro
pensate come sono andato bene ho fatto
un gameplay di circa tre minuti che vi
metto direttamente qua perché troppo
corto per dedicarci un video e niente
guardian the path è pari o dispari fatto
qualcosa così ho vinto io
lancio della partenza nei migliori
ma gli altri non devi darmi una
valutazione schifo
7 grazie
[Musica]
a sinistra fare schifo varie
riesce ancora c'è da qualcuno
eccolo è lui ti tiene dentro
ahimé trovi grazie 39 incredibile ma
esserci sorpasso
questo è visto a 420 lenito il balzo
legge ma non solo per un'altra donna dai
bene
addio
ma al 43
e la prima hanno detto la loro fede uomo
n 240 la protestataria che già era
l'altro play
quanto ai piedi
inaugurata fra questa cosa l'animale che
c'era questa cosa fatta cos'è dopo che
non avete detto di sterminio infatti 21
aiutandoli a rete detto 5 6 ragazzi mi
hanno fatto il culo come era evidente ma
un'apertura del culo e adesso in questo
momento c'è il tecnico che sta smontando
io sarei che è il cancellerà tutti i
dati della playstation in questo momento
così che non si sa che io ho perso è
indotta provano e niente non si va a
prendere la patente ora che ho perso
quindi regazzoli sono è stato un
fenomeno anche con l'ump e grazie a dio
non c'e la patente per ho capito che
siamo e 100 ragazzi cosa è sempre
vissuto momento è un mi piace anche a
pagani facebook e camini lottato nella
descrizione sanseveresi discrete vi si
fidavano prossimo blog e ricami calafati
domanda madonna guidi che gli occhiali
non servono incazzo si sono studioso
stupido uguale favi domanda sono più
sexy conoscenza
vabbè fatemelo sapere io chiudo prima di
sembrare ancora più mongoloide spero che
vi sia per cento ragazzi non significa
che volete vi piace anche la pace di
facebook e con invito a tornare a
schizzare chelsea discreta ci vediamo
prossimo video bene ragazzi